for more than three billion years plants
have been absorbing sunlight with the
help of a green pigment called
chlorophyll during photosynthesis the
leaves transformed the light into energy
allowing plants to grow and produce
oxygen the basis for all life on earth
this energy is truly green at the
University of Kassel
scientists are trying to use the same
principle to generate energy a team of
architects artists scientists and
designers are working on a building
material that will transform sunlight
into electricity like a solar cell
they're using ordinary concrete as their
base
the researchers mix it with graphite so
it can conduct electricity after it's
hardened the special concrete can
function as a positive or negative Pole
that's why carbon cycle closed man is an
artist
Torsten Kloster an architect they came
up with the idea of using conductive
concrete to generate solar power listen
he has leads Edo scheme constant what
you see here looks like ordinary
concrete but what's special about it is
that it's sensitive to the touch as you
can see and that's because we've made
this concrete capable of conducting
electricity and this conductive concrete
is the basis for our solar concrete to
give the concrete the desired
characteristics the scientists spray on
various layers of colored liquid the
result is a dye sensitized solar cell
that produces electricity through
artificial photosynthesis the order in
which the wafer thin layers of color are
applied is all important if you combine
the layers correctly you end up with
something that functions like a
photovoltaic cell one layer contains dye
pigments when sunlight strikes them
electrons are released and current
starts to flow to improve their dye
sensitized solar cells the researchers
conducted long-term measurements in the
lab a single solar cell delivers a
charge of just a few hundred millivolts
if you cover it with your hand the
charge falls sharply and rises again
when light hits the solar cell
the cells efficiency is currently just
2% that's not much but it's a start
solar concrete our discreet is so
interesting because it's really easy to
produce it's environmentally friendly
and can be used on large surfaces maybe
one day in the future all the smooth
flat surfaces in the city could be used
to produce electricity and mild form
poverty and couldn't the more sounds
that are sprayed onto a building's wall
the more electricity it can produce to
do this the individual cells need to be
interconnected under ideal conditions a
surface area of one square meter could
generate 20 watts of power the
researchers hope that one day a facade
robot will scale building walls and
spray them with solar cells the solar
concrete developed in Kassel might be
ready to go into industrial production
in about five years it could be used as
a construction material for new
buildings and to upgrade existing
facades